si monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur eric ciotti merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresser à
monsieur le premier ministre
et cette question concernait la relation
et la place de la garde des sceaux dans
le gouvernement en l'absence du premier
ministre je vais donc la poser
directement à madame la garde des sceaux
depuis un an madame la ministre nos
concitoyens assiste médusé à la
dégradation des relations que vous nous
et avec votre premier ministre il y a un
an vous était au premier rang des
frondeurs au congrès de la rochelle
depuis vous avez à mots à peine couverts
contester le projet doit macron vous
avez critiqué le projet de loi
renseignements mais la semaine dernière
et ce week end vous avez franchi madame
la ministre une étape supplémentaire
dans la provocation à l'égard du premier
ministre
vous n'avez pas hésité à lancer un
ultimatum un ultimatum à votre premier
ministre pour le contraindre de
présenter le projet de loi sur la
délinquance des mineurs que vous portez
et que vous voulez porter je ne
reviendrai pas sur le fond de ce projet
de loi
j'espère pour ma part que nous n'aurons
pas en débattre parce qu'il est animé
par la philosophie qui vous a déjà porté
sur le texte sur la contrainte pénale
avec les conséquences que l'on mesure
sur la sécurité des français
mais sur la forme sur la forme madame la
ministre
c'est j'ai envie de vous demander j'ai
envie de vous demander jusqu'où
irez-vous où vous voulez aller
que cherchez vous est ce que finalement
derrière ses provocations
derrière cet ultimatum inédit sous la
vème république ne se cache pas un
marchandage politiciens est-ce que par
ces critiques
vous ne voulez pas qu'on prenne le
président de la république à vous faire
quitter le gouvernement en vous nommant
la présidence du conseil constitutionnel
ce qui serait un scandale politique
à paroles et quand madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
merci merci beaucoup
allez on est à fond merci
merci monsieur monsieur le président
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
le député eric ciotti
j'avoue que malgré toutes ces années
passées vous conservez pour moi quelque
chose de mystérieux je me demande je me
demande si lorsque vous affirmez
certaines choses vous y croyez vraiment
leur cité du temps de ma fringante
jeunesse j'aurais supposer un sentiment
contrarié mais c'était miscibles tout
entier a déjà constaté à quel point je
vous obsède dans toute votre expression
publique avec une constance qui appelle
quand même l'admiration
alors c'est aussi la première fois que
le premier ministre aurait besoin d'un
défenseur
compte tenu de sa personnalité de son
courage de son autorité nous avons du
mal à comprendre qu'il pourrait non
seulement avoir besoin d'un défenseur
mais en plus à le trouver dans ses rangs
la alors votre perturbations vient de la
justice des mineurs
oui monsieur le député la majorité vous
avez soutenu pendant deux quinquennats a
considérablement perturbé leur donnant
de 45 avec 37 modifications cette
ordonnance est devenue illisible et
cohérente et vous vous livrez un
exercice solitaire
lorsque vous prétendez que les têtes
efficace monsieur le député
ce sujet extrêmement important et tous
ceux qui sont concernés le disent
clairement que ce soit les magistrats et
les professionnels de l'enfance que ce
soir les élus locaux qui plaide compte
pour un terme à ces quelle cohérence et
cette lisibilité que ce soit bien
entendu les victimes qui en ont assez
d'attendre des procès trop tardive nous
allons effectivement amélioré les choses
mais nous n'avons pas besoin de votre
secours
merci merci
merci